IBM case manager an IBM data cap keep
customers in the center of the insurance
claim process when an insurance customer
submits a claim on their mobile device
they easily upload everything required
including photos of the accident taken
at the scene now when the claims
reviewer logs in the submitted claim has
appeared and is ready to be investigated
the claims reviewer can drill down and
see all details of the claim and
relevant material submitted by the
customer such as accident photos are
under a convenient documents tab but
to-do list lays out next steps such as
reviewing the customers policy
information as the claims reviewer
investigates the claim they can also
quickly arrange towing to the nearest
body shop and when the claims reviewer
clicks process the claim moves on to the
claims adjuster now the adjuster has
everything they need to do their job in
one convenient interface they can follow
their own to-do list and can easily
perform actions like adding notes and
since the body shop was automatically
informed earlier of the cars arrival it
has provided additional pictures as well
as a timely repair estimate that the
claims adjuster can now view the
adjuster can make a quick assessment and
submit their resolution
[Music]
using IBM case manager an IBM data cap
the insurance company has streamlined
its processes and responded to its
customers claim at incredible speed
visit ibm.com
and streamline your business with IBM
case manager and IBM data cap